oh old school running back for the
chiefs
oh i don't know that yeah old school
dead one of those players who's the
pacific
you would know azuza azuza zuma's not
even d1 is it
no but he came out of there so people
people can come out of
yeah oh really it's tough enough to make
it a d1 but there's a few exceptions
because i was like do those scouts go to
those schools and check out they don't
even unless you're like
like the best of the best of all time
from that school they might give you an
invite
would they even question like why is he
here if he's like the better like
[ __ ] happens oh really [ __ ] happens what
is it a lot of uh
they might get overlooked had injuries
academics
oh like when we were watching the uh my
college chance you
oh yeah they they got alex college on uh
is it called chanceu
the one where they do it in l.a yeah
yeah i watched two apps i was like this
is
[ __ ] is that the college you went to
yeah bro well it was so funny because
everybody was literally telling me like
hey we found malik scott
[Laughter]
that's my school baby i'm not how about
hey how about the one
the one how about the one review goes
the new season of last chance you is so
cringe
oh really he said it's bad santa i
thought it was dope we were watching it
did you see the original
no with the white coach oh dude
he was good oh my god that sounds like
coach that sounds like the playback
it was oh east los angeles uh community
college that's what it was
east los angeles state tech state tech
technical schools devry university
we graduate on you graduate on a tuesday
the horns come on go to college man what
you doing get up l.a horn
l.a beavers who gives a damn yeah
wait is that the one you went to though
no i wasn't oh but
it was west side i don't know i i wasn't
enjoying that yeah
i didn't want to watch the original oh
it's unreal it's so [ __ ] good
the original is it is it a high school
or a college it's a juco
where you call it all these rejects come
from
and it's the number one hey we're not
rejects at jucos yeah a little bit
it's a yeah come on [ __ ] bad ass
yeah louisville right yeah yeah
oh yeah these guys don't really go to
university they try
some of them do and then you some of you
just realize they're complete flat
there's re
like some of them should like one kid
was like the star at florida state
recruit
was just a total [ __ ] up so he can't
play the you know he gets kicked out so
he ends up at
you know last chance you school and like
kansas
that's what happened to that kid he
played at uh penn state kent state got
it
penn state he got hurt then he started
he started smoking a lot or whatever
blah blah blah and then he went back and
told you the story before
all of them have the same story oh and
then and then on i thought i was hearing
something new
every single juco guy has the same story
they're all [ __ ] up
whether they don't do grades or whatever
or they're just stupid
and then they get like uh the one main
guy and last chance you who
everybody loved he came from like a
rough background everyone cheered for
him
he got invited or he yeah he got invited
to play for the oakland raiders so then
he was on
hard knocks when the raiders were john
gruden out there
yeah and john gruden like he has like
this injury and he's like babying it
and uh he's there for like two days and
they're in the office and grooms like
cut his ass we don't need him he's
[ __ ] terrible
and then he gets caught literally the
next day damn it's so cutthroat huh nfl
soaked up though oh like we don't
[ __ ] need him cut that guy
you know ah man the last chance you guy
damn the other [ __ ] nor good john kim
went to my
he's an alumni at the juco i went to in
texas yeah a lot of i mean jon jones
went to juco like there's
there's a reason why you go to juco yeah
trades
yeah but you're so talented yeah it's
nothing that's why i went it's north
dakota state is that a
no no no no that's a big school why
northern was all gonna say uh
you almost went there come on g i'm
riding with you thank you you almost
watching carson wins carson wentz yeah
bro that's a big school for football
hey well the number three draft pick
this year who is the quarterback the
black kid
oh yeah but he was the first guy from uh
they're ballers like they dominate their
division i think they might be one
double a
but it's big time football for that
division okay so when you went to the
like when you went to the bills they
gave you a contract or they're just like
you sign a contract you sign a cut it's
not a contract
it's not really a contract or it is but
it's you know it might it might as well
be so
like okay bring this job you're gonna be
on our team this is this your contract
you're basically signed away all your
name and likeness
and if you get injured like you know
like yeah i'm not going to give you like
a first-round drive so they give you
like 10 million dollar deal no no no no
no i think i should pay them
and and they took my journey i want to
keep my jersey like nah [ __ ]
yeah damn you gotta watch last chance
the original
the original it's tuesday i watched the
original theo had the coach and i talked
to the coach we're gonna have him firing
the kid
because the coach is born and raised a
white dude from compton and he was like
let's bring him in
he was like the all-time well not now
because he had some [ __ ] go down
he got fired oh because they actually
had a german kid on the team
and he said i'm your hitler because i'm
gonna you do what i say i'm your hitler
and then that kid posted it on social
media got fired
man wait what but the coach is one of
those guys like he's from compton
so he acts real ghetto yeah he's pure
entertainment oh really but he's already
gotta watch he's a really really good
coach
last chance first two seasons first two
seasons because he's somewhere
and then he leaves there i think he and
then goes another one
but he's such a character he talks so
much [ __ ] to the kids
but he relates to him because he came
from the street yeah oh okay
yeah same with this he's used the one
white guy who's the one white
guy compton and it was the baller
quarterback
damn so he relates oh so this is for
football oh yeah because this one is
basketball
oh yeah this is what this is about it's
all i'm telling you that's
horrible yeah i think that ruined the
series oh dude basketball
yeah you got to watch the football one
it's so good
i can't wait why do from columbus
it's so frustrating too because the kids
like they're like man if you just go to
class
you're going to have you have offers
from alabama florida state penn state
kid misses class i mean like and then
this coach like knocks on the dorm room
like dude what are you doing
yeah he's like i'm just tired man he's
like dude all you have
the teacher said she will pass you all
you gotta do is show up
and you have a full ride to florida
state and he misses you
right you know they were about to do
that with me like self-sabotage
uh no um when i switched high schools
and they were they wanted me to play
football uh or whatever
and they were like we'll help you
[ __ ] graduate well because i
i didn't graduate on time eat a dick
what's up what's on your mind
oh no you got something to say you said
play football they didn't want me to bro
i was just fans i played running back
yeah i was just fast i don't know i'm
not going to tell you what it's
3 15 today 10 times all my story with
ease
let me tell you something a video 385
deadlift cold as [ __ ] for [ __ ] i think i
did like four or five
but what i'm saying is i'm not i would
never say i'm a [ __ ]
football player yeah yeah yeah bro i
know no you can't catch
well i can't i can't [ __ ] i can't i
played football for 14 years at a high
level you could probably play football
yeah because you're athletic you're
explosive
bro i'm telling you real you're pretty
nice unless we have crossroads who's
that
uh my mother's dog who's the girl behind
shout out to toby shout out to derek
who's that black guy that's derek uh
green from the band's cell photo
oh that's hard oh that's yeah some fan
did that but that's not it
oh oh y'all was at the view view that
view
my girl still had the titties out
you should see what she wanted to wear
before i'm like we can't we can't do
that
oh wow that was that [ __ ] dessert
[Music]
yeah i cheated on my diet um yeah
i had a little bit we had a little bit i
had a couple fries too
um no yes
did they get me going go back
go back hey where the [ __ ] it go
you you just posted post it like that
you posted the end of the video you know
you [ __ ] up right
oh [ __ ] you can do whatever
all that you can see
let that be me i'm just
giveaway you hit a hundred thousand oh
this is what we do
it's a hundred thousand he will randomly
pick one of his new followers and give
you
uh free merch free yeah i'll give you a
whole love is tight
uh catalog catalog like like catalog i
mean like collections three pieces
three pieces three or four pieces yeah
collection as soon as he hits 100k he's
almost there he's
about ten thousand almost close to 100k
hey but as i was saying listen i don't
think i could have [ __ ] played
football
listen i tried to play flag football and
[ __ ] when i was younger i tried
i gave it a [ __ ] shot okay
[ __ ] i got to catch this ball in
the air
yeah huh yeah it's tough you throw this
ball like
and i and like from a distance yeah and
that ball high as [ __ ] in the air
hand and eye coordination head-9
coronation
if you're running back and we just hand
you the ball then you just got to run
through the hole with your thick ass
oh that's it yeah oh they did call you
jerome better than the podcast the boss
who called me jerome
oh that's the guy from the steelers yeah
i'm not built like him
you have the exact same body uh i think
i used to
yeah but when i went before we started
the workouts i did true we are losing
weight
you know we still don't do i bro
[ __ ]
we still don't look like mark we don't
look like mark how about that when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
bro come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son